commence donc par parler de la canicule
tout le monde le sait il va faire chaud
très chaud
cette semaine on parle de record de
température ressentie est le
gouvernement est mobilisé
écoutez agnès buzyn c'est la ministre de
la santé et elle l'a affirmé ce matin
sur france info
tout est prêt il ne manque pas un bouton
de guêtre tout est prêt à la fois dans
les ehpad dans les hôpitaux dans les
transports la direction générale du
travail envoie des consignes du
ministère des sports des places les
horaires des compétitions bref tout est
organisé
cela dit lorsque les gens sont fragiles
même quand ils boivent beaucoup même
quand tout est organisé il ya toujours
un surplus de mortalité c'était le cas
l'été dernier même si ça a été très très
loin de ce que nous avions connu en 2003
et alors une excuse à la mise sur la
santé n'est pas la seule à se mobiliser
tout le gouvernement est sur le pont y
compris françois de rugy
le ministre de l'ecologie qui après une
décision importante
un ministre sans cravate ce matin que ce
post il serra et vous savez qu'au japon
il ya déjà de nombreuses années les
instructions données
les ministres les dirigeants
d'administrations ne devait pas mettre
de cravates pour montrer l'exemple dans
au travail d'alléger en effet la tenue
vestimentaire pour s'adapter à ces
canicule
patrick plus loin tant que médecin
urgentiste vous êtes toutes premières
loges à chaque fois qu'il ya une
canicule alors je prenais ça sur un ton
un peu un peu sarcastique
non pas que je sous-estiment la gravité
de ce qui peut arriver mais parce que on
a l'impression qu'on infantilise un peu
les français n'ont alors dix ans ne
mettez pas de cravate de ces deux ne
fait pas de sport en pleine chaleur
salaires évident alors d'abord c'est
important de respecter cette culture
française de rire de tout sinon on va
s'ennuyer mais j'ai déjà donc c'est très
bien
deuxièmement par rapport à ce qu'a dit
du rugby vous devriez enlever votre
cravate car en fait vous montez votre
température corporelle de deux degrés de
plus d'accord si vous ne l'aviez pas
donc vous êtes courageux
sauf que sauf qu'à la réalisation d'un
loisir le bureau nous allons nous avons
nous à voir
un peuple qui est plein d'ambiguïtés qui
veut toujours sa liberté mais qui veut
si jamais l'état ne produit pas des
conseils on va dire que l'état ne fait
pas les choses
alors il ya on en parle beaucoup je
pense que c'est nécessaire parce que il
ya beaucoup de gens chez qui il faut
remettre sans art l ouvrage sur l'établi
pour qu'ils comprennent qu'il faut
changer des habitudes mais en même temps
et c'est là où je rejoins un peu agnès
buzyn vous avez eu quand même des
progrès considérables en depuis 2003 on
a muté complètement la société sur la
responsabilité collective et
individuelle pendant l'été je vous coupe
le second rappel 2003 c'était cette
grande canicule où il y avait eu
plusieurs milliers de morts alors nous
on donne le chiffre de 15 mille vous dit
même que cette puce g ils n'ont cessé
milseck azbil c'était en fait il avait
coupé entre le 4 août et le 18 août pour
limiter l'impact politique en fait mais
en fait les chercheurs après ont repris
les chiffres c'était 20007 et 85000 en
europe
à l'époque je suis quelque peu plus
menti ce n'est même pas c'est même pas
la france et l italie sté berlusconi qui
avait dit y'a pas de canicule en italie
et bingo un an après ils ont dit les
vingt-cinq mille morts de plus donc ça a
des conséquences on aide la dans le dur
du réchauffement climatique de l'urgence
à éviter que la planète se réchauffe et
des civilisations comme la france qui
était un petit peu habitués à la chaleur
sur le sud en fête
et bien en fait elles doivent s'habituer
sur des zones où il n'y avait pas d'
habitude de grandes chaleurs comme le
nord comme paris etc
donc c'est très compliqué je suis assez
optimiste parce que je trouve que nous
avons même si en effet c'est un peu
lassant mais ça c'est la problématique d
information continue aussi on vous parle
sans arrêt de la chaleur mais par
exemple vous prenez ce qui se passe dans
les maisons de retraite on a totalement
changé les habitudes il ya des pièces
réfrigéré bien que le problème du too
climatisation va entraîner le
réchauffement climatique de routes et
tuer et fred compliqué c'est très
compliqué il y aura des morts oui il y
aura des morts parce que c'est comme
pour l'épidémie de grippe
en fait là
la canicule tue elle va encore tué cette
année à chaque fois vous avez une
espérance de vie qui diminue pour les
personnes les plus fragiles d'un an et
demi donc ça va nécessairement tués mais
il ya des tas d'incertitudes parce qu'il
ya pas une canicule qui ressemble à une
autre cette année elle va être très
intense très rapide très courte mais ça
veut pas dire qu'on n'est pas un nouvel
épisode caniculaire en juillet ou en
août
on est en pleine mutation
climatologiques
en fait c'est ça qui est très inquiétant
anne-sophie le trac on pose la question
sur lefigaro.fr cette épisode de
canicule précoce vous inquiète-t-il
alors qu'il peut y avoir une inquiétude
personnel ou familial ou une inquiétude
climatique plus global il ya une
majorité de gens qui semblent pas trop
trop s'inquiéter
est ce que c'est votre cas alors je
crois pas personnellement je sais pas
effectivement là le ciel plombé un peu
un peu gris est très très chaude pisse
pas très agréable mais c'est
complètement anecdotique
ce qui m'inquiète ce qui m'inquiète en
vérité c'est que effectivement d'une
certaine manière vous posez la question
donc canicule en fait on trop à court
terme c'est à dire sur sûr immédiatement
fin sur ce qui se passe dans l'immédiat
vraiment oui et ça rejoint ça rejoint ce
qu'on fait effectivement vous avez tout
à fait raison monsieur pelouse sur sur
les télévisions on continue il ya une
espèce de dramatisation voir quelque
chose d'apocalyptique dans la manière de
traiter la météorologie aujourd'hui et
je précise bien que je ne minimise
absolument pas le réchauffement
climatique je ne parle pas de ça jeudi
qu' il ya aussi une espèce de il ya
quelque chose qui rapporte beaucoup à
effrayer à infantiliser donc sa sage je
trouve que c'est assez frappant les
faits c'est qu'on se ruent sur l'eau qui
a plus d'eau dans les magasins
construits sur les climatiseurs qui vont
aggraver le réchauffement climatique je
trouve qu'il ya une forme
d'irrationalité également même si le
gouvernement par ailleurs j'en suis
certaine a pris la mesure de ce qui
s'est passé il ya un péché originel en
fait qu'ils étaient 2003 et depuis on
craint de subir la punition divine
chaque fois qu'il ya une canicule on
saura puni pour ses vingt mille morts et
c'était absolument terrifiant mais il ya
quelque chose aussi du péché originel
quand on pense je sors un tout petit peu
du sujet a great attenberg qui la petite
jeune fille qui a 14 ans qui explique il
faut que vous soyez effrayé que vous
soyez terrifiée parce que vous avez fait
à la planète
on voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose il
ya quelque chose d'apocalyptique et ça
ça me dérange beaucoup
dernière chose que je voulais dire
il me semble que ceci cache des
problèmes beaucoup plus structurelle que
faisons nous de nos personnes âgées des
gens qui sont isolées n'ont plus
personne ne s'occupe
il faut rappeler tout le temps qu'il
faut téléphoner à ces personnes âgées
tannique il apparaît comme un révélateur
révélateur de le problème extrêmement
grave parce que effectivement et l'autre
problème c'est qu'effectivement les
îlots de chaleur que sont les les
grandes villes pose le problème de
l'urbanisation très clairement
l'organisation qui est remise en cause
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de l'espace qui
n'ont pas de nature pas d'eau pas de sol
qui absorberait à la chaleur est
aujourd'hui même s'il ya un aménagement
de ces villes
il est certain que le problème se pose
il n'y aura plus 2,5 degrés en 2050
c'est certain et deux tiers des
habitants du monde vivront dans des
métropoles donc il faut que la question
se pose et dernière chose dernière des
dernières pourquoi continuer à
construire des autoroutes stupide qui ne
servent à rien comme par exemple la 69
qui va toulouse à castres pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas arrêter le réchauffement
climatique en faisant en même
difficilement vont pas directement la
canicule mais je crois que c'est un
sujet qui vous tient à ce qu'il veut
sans vous avoir déjà sur ce thème alors
jusqu'au gouvernement
donc je vous disais on est mobilisé
alors comme il est 17h13 et qu'on est en
direct c'est la fin de la journée pour
les élèves d'en capter des directeurs
d'école qui nous écoutent
alors j'aurai vous lire cette cette
recommandation du ministère de
l'éducation nationale ainsi qu'un
document tout à fait officielle alors il
ya d'une manière générale garder les
enfants dans une ambiance fraîche fermer
les volets et les rideaux éviter les
exposition prolongée au soleil sport
promenade en plein air
et alors ça va je l' ai beaucoup
distribuer régulièrement de l'eau à
température ambiante entre parenthèses
veiller à sa qualité
ça c'est pour les directeurs qui veulent
aller dans le caniveau dans votre
histoire devant l'école pour y récupérer
de l'eau il ya des parents qui vont
prendre la tête aux enseignants s'il n'y
avait pas cette note 1 il ya des casses
couilles
enfin les rappels sont 100% quand même
que c'est tous les ministres c'est ce
que dit cette suite laquelle il ya la
malédiction du ministre de la santé de
2003 on se dit alors moi jamais assez
c'est le traumatisme de 2003 dans la
classe politique si vous voulez ce
pauvre jean françois mattei qui est à
marseille chez lui en vacances qui
réunissent de la skil et nice de la
santé qui ne prend pas la mesure mais
comme tous les gens qui étaient dans le
sud à l'époque comme les et patrick
pelouse dans le sud à l'époque oui on
sait qu'il fait chaud bah quand il fait
chaud on va se baigner soit dans la mer
soit éventuellement de sa piscine
donc on ne mesure pas du tout parce que
ça fait il n'y a pas eu de canicule
depuis très longtemps et donc on ne
mesure pas la gravité et j'en sens
mettez y arriver ce qui lui était
reproché c'est à la fois le propos est
la tenue de ce qu'il était en polo il
n'est pas remonté à paris en urgence et
et on le voit oui alors sur un polo
c'est plus juste plus compliqué mais on
le voit tout de suite sur les courbes de
popularité jacques chirac jean pierre
raffarin voient leur cote de popularité
s'effondrer parce qu'ils n'ont pas pris
la mesure des quinze à vingt mille morts
il y en a un qui tire son épingle du jeu
admirablement alors qu'il n'est pas là
qu'il est à tunis à bizerte plus
exactement et que
c'est quand même à paris qui a le plus
grand nombre de morts c'est bertrand
delanoë parce que tout le monde se
retourne vers l'état et part vers le
maire et ça c'est totalement incroyable
histoire je garde un souvenir de jean
françois de raffarin
parce que raffarin lui est remonté tout
de suite et on avait eu une réunion ça
devait être le 9 août ou le 10 août et
j'avais été invité à une réunion à
matignon avec avec raffarin et là il ya
un préfet qui explique qu'on n'a plus du
tout de place dans les morgues rester la
réalité c'est-à-dire qu'on
réquisitionnait les véhicules
frigorifiques pour mettre des macchabées
et là il ya le préfet tout de go qui dit
ah mais vous savez on a trouvé une
solution on met des cadavres tête bêche
ah ouais ils ont mis à rungis mais voilà
il mettait les cadavres dans les belles
journées là et là je regarde je regarde
battait je lui fais et et pâques rapa et
tu te sens tu sais pas ce que c'est
vraiment un homme d'état qui reprend le
truc qui dit vous arrêtez ça tout les
ils étaient totalement perdus mais je
pense parce que honey au sommet en fait
il me laisse dépérir pas anticipé ça
n'était pas préparée et aujourd'hui on
ne peut plus dire ça un politique qui
dirait on savait pas on annonce est
finie la et d'aude où l'excès de
précaution avec ses notes on a un peuple
qui a besoin de ça moi je ne remets base
pour aller un peu dans votre sens parce
qu est ce qui est agaçant c'est le fait
d'avoir que des gens qui sont dans une
irresponsabilité c'est le joggeur qui
valait courir à 14 heures en pleine
chaleur vous envoyer d'envoi on trouve
ben voilà c'est un peu n'importe quoi
quand même hein et les patrons qui vont
obliger les ouvriers à travailler dans
l'anc
donc il ya une responsabilité c'est pour
ça que c'est c'est un peu agaçant mais
il ya une responsabilité collective mais
qui ne peut pas remplacer la le bon sens
individuels dans le propos de votre
voisine
il y avait un élément sur le une forme
de catastrophisme écologique
c'est-à-dire l'idée que peut-être on
dramatise à l'excès cette canicule
parce que c'est cesser dans le discours
ambiant sur le thème ça va être la fin
du monde bientôt comme la jeune suédoise
greta 30 base nous le promet avec son
visage souriant oui il ya aujourd'hui
une ambiance de sur la colonne zoologie
ces gens qui préparent justement la fin
du monde oui oui on sait c'est tout un
courant qui dit de toute façon c'est
trop tard peu importe les efforts qu'on
pourra faire le changement climatique
est acté il va aller de plus en plus
vite parce qu'il ya un déclic en fait à
partir de la fonte qui fait que les
courants d'air vont complètement changer
et de et bien une ère glacière ou enfin
un vrai changement climatique
donc vous avez un courant de pensée qui
est de l'ordre parfois de la croyance en
disant voilà on ne pourra pas empêcher
essai c'est une apocalypse qui arrive et
puis vous avez ressenti réels c'est à
dire que notre pays est encore moins
impacté que d'autres mais je pense aux
états unis qui ont des feux
catastrophique chaque année qui
détruisent la côte ouest qui ont des
tornades des inondations qui souffrent
aussi de canicule les etats-unis s'est
encore beaucoup plus grave la chine
aussi qu'ils sont des pieds aux
premières loges de ce changement
climatique parce que extrêmement
urbanisées et peu habituée aux fêtes et
nous en france ça commence à venir on a
aussi des épisodes maintenant les
épisodes cévenols qui se répètent les
tornades les canicules qui se
multiplient et on n'est pas préparé
et effectivement c'est les premiers
soubresauts peut-être d'un vrai
changement de long terme de la
température de la façon dont on va vivre
aussi s'organiser est ce que la ville
est un bon terrain pour vivre entre
humains peut-être pas dans le futur
enfant voit déjà
l'urbanisation galopante les ravages qui
ceux qui se font en afrique de ces
mégapoles de bidonvilles qui arrive un
peu partout donc il ya une vraie
question sur
ce modèle là est ce qu est ce qu on est
préparés alors on se prépare on a les
moyens nous on peut effectivement
changer changer la donne mais ce
discours là il est réel enfin il existe
il est entendu et il est corroboré par
certains faits alors bien sûr une
canicule c'est pas un changement
climatique mais c'est une petite pierre
de plus sur le chemin du regardez c'est
en train de changer de manière
catastrophique
il ya un article très intéressant de le
roy ladurie qui quand même relativiser
un certain nombre de choses c'est à dire
qu'il évoque des canicules de 1718 1719
qui ont fait sept cent mille morts à
l'époque effectivement qu'il n'y avait
pas la révolution industrielle il n'y
avait pas oui quand on parle aux
thématiques et il évoque notre canicule
celle de 1788 qui a évidemment mis à mal
toutes les ressources et un an après on
a la solution
il ya un autre facteur qui joue là c'est
l'arrivée en france du moustique tigre
qui est très inquiétante et qui fait
qu'en fait une partie des par isitolo j
ai des virus qui sont en afrique vont
arriver l'endurance est avec le
réchauffement climatique il faut
craindre l'arrivée du palu en france et
alors là si tel était le cas et si on
n'arrive pas à juguler ça là ça va être
très compliqué pour nos petits corps
occidentaux et le moustique tigre ça
fait plusieurs années qu'il est là et on
a pas d'augmentation du palu et remonte
non non non c'est notamment là si vous
avez eu des chiens ou non on le trouve
n'existe pas encore heureusement pour la
palestine explique alors député
internautes
babineau qui est fidèle au poste on est
au delà du simple conseil on est dans
une communication gouvernementale
absolument délirante infantilisés et le
bon mot et puis ce propos rassurants
d'olympe qui nous dit je suis une
vieille dame dans un immeuble des années
60 sans clim et ma foi je survis on
citait ce chiffre est inquiétant de 15
villes voire vingt mille morts en 2003
sauf que j'ai lu vous allez me dire si
c'est juste patrick peloux qu'en fait
les statistiques annuelles de mortalité
elle n'était pas si différente que ça
c'est des gens qui étaient en situation
de faiblesse et qui de toute façon
serait morte donne
dans la rue dans les mois qui allait
venir et que ça va juste accéléré les
choses justes avec toutes les guillemets
qui s'impose je connais bien cet
argument en effet on va tous mourir ceux
qui nous regardent désolé mais on va
tous mourir bon et c'est un peu ce
qu'avait dit mattei d'ailleurs quand il
avait dit ils avaient fait une
communication catastrophique à la
commission d enquête parlementaire où il
avait levé son bras comme ça puis
l'avait dit ces lieux qui a décidé avait
fait si si ça je m'en rappellerai vu ça
et en fait ce qu'il est l'inserm avait
étudié justement ce chiffre est en fait
en moyenne ce qui était décédé avait
quand même un an et demi d'espérance de
vie et c'est vrai que la canicule de
toute façon va taper les premiers qui
vont et qui vont être victimes ce sont
les sans domicile fixe qui meurent plus
l'été que l'hiver parce que c'est plus
difficile de se protéger de la chaleur
que du froid les deuxièmes c'est les
travailleurs de force et les sportifs et
les sportifs il ya il ya des sportifs
qui meurent d'un arrêt cardiaque et 10
permis maligne dû à l'effort et
l'hyperthermie malling c'est s'est dit
on c'est céline le premier ennemi du
soldat par exemple c'est pour vous dire
que l'armée connaissait très bien depuis
très longtemps et puis après les
personnes qui sont avec des maladies
chroniques les handicapés et les bien
sûr évidemment ce qui rassemble tout ça
ce sont ce sont les personnes âgées
donc c'est vrai que ce qu'ils se sont
dit oui mais mes s'aggravait et à
diminuer leur espérance de vie
ce qui est donc un critère de
surmortalité voilà merci on disait que
il fut un temps où les canicules
entraîner des révolutions c'est
peut-être ce qu'espère jean luc
mélenchon par exemple cette transition
un peu laborieuse